[Musik]
was anziehen so neben sichtlich scheint
die frage
und doch sie ist alltäglich wie
entscheide ich was ich trage welche
blicke beeinflussen wie frei entscheiden
die professorin und designerin bitten
städter setzt sich in ihrer arbeit mit
diesen fragen auseinander
wir wollen ja nicht ausgegrenzt werden
sondern wir wollen ja dazu gehören
insofern sind wir natürlich nicht frei
wir bewegen uns immer in diesem
spannungsfeld von distinktion und
nachahmer ermüdung von dem was wir
anhatten und dem wunsch nach neuen die
mode sie umhüllt verschönert
verschlimmert teils vor allem definiert
sie was schön sein soll
und überraschung vor allem bei frauen
ist dünn seien immer noch das ideal
die aktuelle mode unterstreicht es
normalerweise ändert sich die mode so
alle fünf jahre sagt man so jetzt
beobachten wir das schon seit 15 jahren
die schmale skinny jeans oder leggings
und leggings und wie sie auch genannt
wird sich durchsetzt auf dem straßenbild
und das soll natürlich irgendwie auch
zeigen was wir an uns gearbeitet haben
[Musik]
von wirklicher individualität scheinen
wir weit entfernt nach außen zeigt sich
die mode dezent zurückhaltend nicht zu
auffällig
tatsächlich interessant dass es darunter
unter der kleidung
wir arbeiten an einem gesunden und
gestählten körper yoga fitness schritte
zählen ein irrsinn auf zwei beinen
unsere leistungsoptimierte gesellschaft
treibt und übertreibt
neu ist das nicht aber dicker werden die
unterwäsche models auch nicht trotz
vereinzelter kritik
für all jene denen 100 gramm brokkoli
pro tag nicht reichen hat die mode den
neuesten optimierungs trick für
untendrunter shapewear riesiger bereich
für die mode geworden also das was wir
vor ein paar jahren noch in apotheken
oder gesundheits leben gefunden haben
kompression suzan finden wir jetzt halt
bei h&m und bei palmers in schön
gestalteter form auch in erotischer form
also eigentlich das was da hat sich eben
das schön oder dir das euro tische mit
dem funktionalen vielmehr verstärkt ein
enges regime gilt auch wenn frau
erfolgreich sein will
blusen blazer perlenkette das ist die
karriere klamotte für business frau oder
politikerin mit netzstrümpfen ist da nix
und wehe frau gibt sich zu individuell
wie schlimm calmy-rey theresa may
hillary clinton oder angela merkel sie
alle
anders als ihre männlichen kollegen
wurden scharf kritisiert für modische
abweichungen frauen auf dieser ebene
dürfen nicht zu weiblich nicht zu grell
sein
das wird als unprofessionell gewertet
[Musik]
fest steht unsere kleidung ist durch das
soziale umfeld geprägt durch norman
kultur und religion
so kann aus einem stück stoff ein
politikum werden
in der ausstellung von der künstlerin
elena sieht man dieses stückchen stoff
in all seinen varianten die
religionswissenschaftlerin dorothea
lükens erkennt in den bildern die
gesellschaftliche tragweite des
reizthema cent blättern und das
ausziehen er immer weiter
fortgeschritten ist und da gibt es jetzt
menschen die ganz gezielt sagen ich
möchte einen teil meines körpers in der
regel die haare ja nur möchte ich
freiwillig bedecken und das steht wie in
dem widerspruch in einer gesellschaft
die sagt meint wir wollen alles und
jedes permanent sich vorhaben
gleichzeitig ist es aber auch gerade für
manche frauen ein grund zu sagen ich
stehe eben nicht zur verfügung und zeige
dass durch meine kleidungsstil
was anziehen als ob das so einfach wäre
mode grenzt ein grenzt aus befolgt
normen und bricht sägen sie schmeichelt
und provoziert wirklich frei ist dabei
niemand
aber
[Musik]